we got damn santa
this special elf that we have who
has the formula to make waffle dust she
comes out
and one of the things that she does
before we take take off again
is she hovers and she sprinkles waffle
dust all over the reindeer oh yeah and
all over the sleigh
and then right there beside me on the
sleigh is a giant
bag of waffle dust goddamn right okay
because i'll tell you what
i travel to some of the places in the
world and the
weather's just terrible i mean it's
really really bad
yeah and you don't want santa and the
sleigh sliding off these
icy roofs so what we do is we circle the
house sprinkle a little waffle dust on
it
and that way the reindeer have sheer
footing whenever they land
i like that yeah will mrs claus kind of
uh
does she have like a favorite meal that
she prepares for you kind of
yes cookies all the time cookies really
so that's not just a myth right no
that's not a myth
i love every kind of cookie there is so
when a children ask me what's my
favorite cookie
i say i love all the cookies i've never
met a cookie i didn't like
do you remember me when i was a kid or
no oh i do you were quite a handful
in was i yeah
but you had fun you turned out pretty
good thank you santa's coming
santa santa's coming
dude i remember growing up in louisiana
they had a they did an event
every year and an event is like
something where you don't
you know it's like regular time but it's
more special than that
and um they used somebody would
fly in a plane through the air
around town and they would play
christmas music
out the plane this was a small plane a
crop duster
so they put on these jovial tunes and
they would hit the air
and so moms they would bring us outside
on the porch about maybe 6
40. and say do you hear it do you hear
it
and they would just be like dashing
through this you know it would be this
something
you hear and it would just be it would
blow your mind
and it lifted you up with that christmas
spirit
and i thought that that was so special
that a town did that that they invested
in that sort of thing
and i think that that's important that
kind of stuff
because that you know who knows if that
moment right there might have
you know kept the magic alive in me
and made me believe in things because
you know santa is something you believe
in but it's something that's just your
it's just your first kind of
it's kind of like your first romance in
a weird way
you know you're hopeful and you're
excited and there's
possibility and there's a date there's
december 25th
and it's just
you know it has all the elements of
romance but no sex
nobody getting six
and there's something that you know
there's something special about that
because i think if you can make that
time romantic enough to a child in an
and you know or you know
you know romance but non-sexual to it
you know if you can make it
entertaining enough to a child in that
way then it can um
they'll carry that same ambiance
and the same belief of possibility into
the world
i'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could i be
so far from my home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been